We have seen a glimpse of fully
associative caches, so now let's go from
the other direction, which is let's
first look at direct-mapped caches.
If this is the memory, and
it contains blocks 0, 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, etc., and these are the block
numbers, not the addresses.
So I'm assuming that this thing here is
an entire block worth of memory which
contains multiple locations.
And let's say we have a cache
with room for four blocks.
We can number the lines 0, 1, 2,
and 3, and in a direct map cache,
block 0, if it's in the cache at all,
needs to be in line number 0.
Block 1, if it's in the cache at all,
will be in slot number 1.
Block number 2, if it is in the cache
at all, has to be in this place here.
Block number 3, if it is in
the cache at all, has to be here.
And now block number 4 will, again,
get to map to line number 0.
Block number 5 maps to line number 1.
Block number 6 maps to line number 2,
etc.
So, pretty much for
any given block address
there is only one place in the cache
where that address can be.
If we look at the memory address,
the least significant bits
are still the block offset.
They tell us where in the block are we,
assuming that we find the block.
The block number now contains some bits
that tell us where in
the cache this block can be.
The index bits need to be sufficient to
tell us which of the lines in the cache
are we talking about.
So if there are four lines in the cache,
then we need two index bits to
tell us where a block can map.
And that is why in the block number
it was 0, 1, 2, 3, 0, 1, 2, 3, etc.
It was determined by the lowermost
bits of the block number, and
the remaining bits of
the address are now the tag.
Now, there is an interesting
question of why the tag
does not include the full block number.
So, why doesn't the tag
cover also the index bits?
And the answer to this is
that the tag needs to tell
us which of the blocks do
we have in this place.
And the answer is that the tag needs
to identify which block we have
in the cache.
Considering that the block would some
in those bits has to be in one
place in the cache, the tag for
that place in the cache doesn't need
to tell us what the index bits are.
By looking at this particular
line we have already determined
that these index bits have to be
the ones that correspond to that line.
So all we have to do is tell us which
of the lines that can possibly be
here do we really have, and for that we
only need these bits, because the index
bits are pretty much predetermined
once we are already looking here.
In other words,
if we stored the index bits in the tag,
all of the tags that we could possibly
put here would have the same index bits,
which means we don't have to store them,
because we already know them.